I watched I think at the time like every
single coming out video on YouTube
hearing their stories and everything
comforted me so much there are so many
people that I could like really really I
would love to meet and say thank you to
I do like ten push-ups sometimes I'll do
star jumps - I'm feeling like a bit
crazy the first one that I came added to
me who has like since come out is not
straight is a Miley Cyrus I remember she
when I was like 13 or whatever and
watching Hannah Montana I thought she
was like the coolest person in the world
and she wrote a song called my heart
beats for love she said in an interview
that it was about her gay best friend
and I was like oh my god Miley Cyrus is
a gay best friend why am I not that
person and I was like if everyone in the
world rejects me can just go become
friends with Miley Cyrus I would say try
not stress I know that that is like it
seems like such a silly thing to say but
really there are people in the world who
1000% will love you like just the way
you are
it came about with Alessi and I like
mates and we had met a couple of times
and I covered her song here on the radio
and then she covered my song use on the
radio and I like texted I was like okay
well I'm gonna one-up you and cover I
think I was threatened her with wild
things and she was like well no let's do
something official and I was like sweet
let's do it and she went into the studio
and she recorded her bare some wild and
I like lost my mind I can't commit to
anything like stylistically for the rest
of my life so I would just get probably
super super simple my family's names or
initials or something like that
[Music]
the only way that I like knew I was
ready to come out was I was being driven
crazy by the fact that I was not out
every single time I was alone with like
either of my parents for a split second
I was like oh my god am I going to do it
now is this the time how can I get the
conversation to go there and it was
literally driving me insane I thought I
was going nuts and it's so weird because
it's one of those things that you build
up you know I built this up for like 15
years in my head and then it's like two
words and it's over always put ketchup
on my mac and cheese always I think I
have to kind of be aware of how much
power words can have and yeah it makes
me consider everything that I say before
I say it because yeah you know you can
you can really help a lot of people or
you can really really mess things up and
so um yeah just trying to be smart and
and helpful firstly ask his permission
Huracan and then I mean if he's down go
all out like pride flags glitter
obviously the playlist is very important
to like a lot of Madonna
[Music]
I love when people make like these
collaborative books I get these like
booklets and it's it's letters from a
bunch of different people and they like
warm my heart so much I love love love
reading the MoMA tour bus and stuff it's
on my right this one definitely the
writing yeah I love love love love love
song writing and that whole you know I
don't know for me it's like the most
therapeutic thing look I didn't realize
how much um me hiding my sexuality also
meant that I hate it like a lot of just
my identity as a person I think I
realize now I was really really scared
too um you know express myself to be
like fashion or like certain music or
like certain TV shows I was petrified
that anyone would ever think I was gay
or forbid and so um once I got over that
I kind of like could just let myself be
um I realized that yeah it's it's you
know I'm I'm kind of a different person
than I thought I was I